the 46 year old executive with Huawei
one of the world's biggest smartphone
companies and a symbol of Chinese
economic heft brought before a court the
bail hearing in Vancouver to determine
if mung Hwan Jo can go free while her
case proceeds it continues today after
Monday's adjournment her lawyer argues
high-tech surveillance and a 24-hour
security detail be allowed to keep her
out of jail during proceedings US
prosecutors say Hmong used a shell
company for hua ways dealings with Iran
misleading banks into approving millions
of dollars in transactions that violated
sanctions arrested in Canada she faces
extradition to the US on Monday her
lawyer said huawei sold the alleged
shell company sky comm years earlier but
the paper trails complicated sky comm
was bought in 2007 by a company in
Mauritius a known tax haven where
ownership records are opaque the case
against Hmong is now set to unfold
against the backdrop of a tense us-china
trade dispute a dispute many hoped was
approaching a resolution but that was
before Hmong Juan Jose arrest